whoa
[Music]
yeah I'm like 98 sure I will be able to
guess this expert I think there's
probably like a whole skill set that
goes into that and I think it will
probably come out getting kisses from
like five or whoever many people I don't
know I've never done anything like this
I don't think you can tell that much
about a person based on a kiss to be
honest I think you can tell a lot about
the connection between you potentially
foreign
[Music]
no I don't think I can guess based on
based on that
the kisser I
I think it's so far I agree and that I
don't think that being a good kisser can
really say much about who you are as a
person but really rather give and
receive like body language with the
person that you're kissing hey hi can I
kiss you yes
I grew up Catholic
I went to Catholic school for two years
number two is going high on the list
partly because of the communication I'm
maybe like giving away my rubric here
but I think maybe
um I'll love you we'll be great friends
like I'll have your back I think all
that honestly can be told like from my
kiss I'm being so honest permission to
kiss Ferguson granted
foreign
that was really sweet passionate like
passionate for sure there was there was
tongue
maybe this expert being somebody who
kind of like teaches other people
intimacy willful this is the word that
comes to mind like gonna go for it bam
kind of thing
oh my God here's how I make decisions it
will just hit me
[Music]
yeah I've gotten complete but I've been
told I was horrible my intent with the
kiss is sort of trying to read another
person's body language
oh
wow
it was like a sneak attack
[Music]
do you feel like that could be this
expert
um
no I feel like this expert would do this
expert thing and like try not to
throw me off but yeah yeah I wouldn't
say that mm-hmm
really fun that was like a fun
I sensed the fun in that one
I think kissing to me is
ex kissing depends on the chemistry
between two people the kiss to me tells
everything I don't feel like I could
tell if they're a good person bad person
or this it's not even about me some
being kissing well or not it's five
senses connection you have to like
everything about the way they feel the
way they everything
oh
how would you like to kiss
I I would would you like to to do this
for another couple seconds sure
whoa
is that lipstick oh my god did you get
it all no that's my mark that's okay
I'll take some for the road
probably this expert I appreciate the
the sort of lead-in I think actually
that's really important to me I in real
life
I spend a lot of time in that sort of
build up
that actually built a lot of like
intimacy I was surprised it was very
intimate you feel it I do I feel it
I think number five is this expert nine
I'm gonna say 85 sure the other 15 is
I'm gonna put it on
uh number two both of them established
safe context taking the time a little
bit of communication asking permission
uh both of them did that kind of in
different ways
my guess is uh I'm gonna go with number
five
I am not ah
thank you now I know who is though
[Laughter]
number two
the kissing itself it's so unique to
every person so it's hard to tell things
like
career or
um you know sexual orientation or things
like that but I think kissing is what
you make it and it's ultimately up to
you to decide what you want that to mean
[Music]
foreign
[Music]